miss van G miss van G me Vangie oh there
[ __ ] let me not jump into her interview
[Music]
and what was the quote of the season I
mean she broke the Internet
miss van g ms banjee miss Benji Benji if
you're not watching the show you know
the words miss van G and you know they
have to be said three times in a row
once twice thrice miss van she miss
banshee miss van G if you're nasty how
much the best one is the third one where
like she was just like deflate it was
like Ramsey banjee miss bans Angie miss
Mandie
there I said it Oh God miss Angie miss
van what about Miss Yuri can we make
that work
no it's not the same effect as a Miss
banjee
miss van G miss Vangie miss right three
times girl that's how you make it okay
mrs. Angie love that [ __ ] she is a
sensation Angie she's right over there
she's like Miss Vangie miss Vangie
banjee
oh let me not let me not jump into her
interview going I'm gonna I'm gonna send
her home again goodbye to Angie
goodbye Angie well I'm not gonna say
myself cuz I don't wanna be that [ __ ]
be that [ __ ] be them Angie miss van g
ms Benji will you ever stop leaving
rooms that way no now why they cut my
check with that I'm gonna keep saying it
it's a like Whitney's up they knew I was
there I got you
banjee
[Music]
you
[Music]